and now lin-manuel Miranda I would say
you don't look the easiest of children
you recently tweeted some letters these
are genius these are letters you wrote
to your parents frog from 40 summer camp
yeah okay so the one is the first one's
kind of a form letter so it's hi from
camp
dear Mom and Dad how are you in hell
yesterday I realized that my tent was
full of morons these really annoying
kids our buddy
tomorrow excruciatingly boring class
begins I can't wait to go home please
have me some Mad Magazine something like
that lovely Miranda yes the kids are
okay if you get used to them is all his
own work this this contains drawings and
also it's on Garfield papers you know
he's taking it seriously yes dear family
hi remember me I'm the kid you ditched
in the woods for a month you know how we
hardly ever go to Mass well I go every
Sunday here's a picture to remind you of
me it's you jumping off a building
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I did it was the performance of my life
I'm not proud of it as an adult and if
my kids ever ask about it I'll deny it
but I faked a spinal injury
there was a kid who hurt his back and
got to go home and I went today I was
alone with a friend of mine I threw
myself on the floor I pretended I
couldn't feel my legs and I was rushed
to the hospital and I had to keep up
this performance all summer and I had a
fake limp and I went to I had x-rays at
Bellevue Hospital in New York City and
but I went home
[Applause]
[Music]